so let's get started
and let's start with the boring stuff so
my name is Vlad of vladi kananov I am a
software architect and a cloud architect
I specialize primarily in distributed
systems and domain driven design
speaking of which
does anyone here already have my latest
book learning to my German design
awesome I see a few hands the rest of
you you know what to do right I don't
have to say it aloud
now today I'm not going to talk about
domain driven designs I really love this
subject but today I want to talk about
the material from my upcoming book
balancing coupling in software design
to be honest it was supposed to be
published like a year and a half or even
two years ago but you know I'm a
software engineer so I have to be bad at
estimates so don't blame me for that
part of our job so anyway I want to give
you a preview of this book today now
this is not going to be a teaser like to
advertise against to raise some interest
in the book no you'll get some practical
tools that you can use right away
if one day
I finished this book before it finishes
me then you already know the basic stuff
from it
so let's get started
there is one quote that lately I've been
using almost all of my presentations so
this time in this one I said hey why
should we wait for the middle or the end
I'll I'm going to put it right there on
the first slide and this is quote by
Ruth Milan she says
system design is inherently about
boundaries what's in what's out what
spends what moves between and it's about
trade-offs it reshapes what is outside
just as it shapes what is inside and I
wanted that quote right there on the
first slide because it outlines the
overall subject of this talk system
design and more specifically the
relationships that span across
boundaries involving the thing that we
fear the most coupling
and you know we've always been told that
coupling is bad it's evil coupling slows
us down it cripples our systems when
working on a code base that doesn't
cooperate with us a code base that
resists any changes you want to make
of course you're going to blame it on
coupling
so as a result not surprisingly what do
we want to do about it
well of course we want to decouple
everything
we have to break everything apart into
those tiny tiny classes objects
microservices to dates or rather
yesterday these were serverless
functions
whatever the motivation is always the
same we want to be able to change every
one of those little boxes independently
however what your results are we getting
by focusing on the size of those
entities
in many cases we go from coupled piles
of code
to distributed piles of code
and in a sense that's not surprising as
my friend Matia says here going for as
small as possible is almost universally
a bad advice in software design also as
Neptune puts it there are many useful
and revealing heuristics for defining
the boundaries of a service but size is
one of the least useful
and yet we keep on doing that
so I know in a sense it's going to sound
somewhat controversial but instead of
fighting coupling in this talk I want to
show you a different way of thinking
about it and I will even try to convince
you that we can use coupling as a tool
for Designing modular systems
that's our agenda in the next 40 minutes
or so we are going to explore the nature
of that scary Beast that we call
coupling we'll start by analyzing what
coupling is exactly sorry
we are going to analyze how coupling
manifests itself in different dimensions
and ultimately how we can use all that
knowledge to design modular systems
so first what is coupling
if we go to the lexical origins of this
word it will take us all the way back to
Latin where it was composed of two words
meaning fasting together
in other words if two things are coupled
it means that they are connected
that makes coupling ubiquitous
phenomenal it is everywhere this clicker
right here it is coupled to my computer
organs in our bodies are coupled to
form us living organisms producing code
or in my case right now insane amount of
stress hormones
anyway cars computers cities organisms
for that matter any kind of system is
held together by coupling you cannot
build a system if all of its components
are going to be disconnected this is
just collection of some parts
simply grouping them together in some
boundary without making sure that they
are able to work together without
connecting them
in just a bunch of a fully independent
and fully decoupled entities but that's
not a system
for a system we need these relationships
these connections between the components
so couplings coupling makes the
overarching system
it makes its value greater than the sum
of its parts therefore
makes no sense to try and decouple
everything
because coupling is an important part of
system design
we cannot design a system without those
interactions
so
in my opinion it makes more sense to
evaluate those inner component
relationships that we have in a system
and evaluate whether they're working for
us or against us
for example say we have
these two coupled components the
downstream references and thus depends
on the Upstream component
the arrow between them that relationship
it defines how these components are
integrated it defines how change in the
Upstream is going to
whether it's likely or not to break the
integration and require cascading
changes in other parts of the system in
Downstream components that are
referencing it
as Michael lagard says coupling defines
the component's degrees of freedom how
freely the components are able to change
without affecting the rest of the system
or in other words
the way the components are integrated it
defines what changes can we make to the
Upstream here without being afraid to
break the Integrations and break the the
system and require cascading changes in
other components of that system
the interfaces that are used for
integration they have to enable some
movements or changes but they also have
to prohibit others
now this prohibits others part I know it
may sound limiting but actually we don't
want unlimited degrees of freedom
that would render any system overly
complex and simply unusable for example
I don't want this clicker to be coupled
to my phone a car or that share for that
matter it makes no sense unlimited
degrees of freedom is chaos
instead we want to make some
Integrations and changes safe while
restraining those that we are not
interested in
in other words the design of
cross-component interactions should
align the allowed degrees of freedom
with our needs and expectations of
future changes in the system we are
designing
and that makes coupling a first-class
design decision
going back to Ruth Milan's quote you
want to design what spans and what moves
between the boundaries in a way that
enables only the changes and movements
that we actually need
to do that we have to understand the
Dynamics of coupling how it works and
how it manifests itself the thing is
coupling is not some unidimensional
phenomena like it's there or not now
it's more complicated it affects a
system or the whole system design in
multiple dimensions and the dimensions
of space time and the combination of
these two gravitational force if you
will
let's go over these dimensions
I'm going to start with strength because
that's where we're going to spend the
most of our time today that's going to
be the heavy one
so the effect of strength is probably
the most obvious hflex sort of
gravitational force that pulls
components together it defines what is
the impact of a change in one place of a
system is going to be on its other
components the harder the strength the
more cascading changes will follow
and as our industry evolved a number of
models were introduced for evaluating
strength of coupling namely coupling in
the structural design methodology and a
model called kinesins
who here is familiar with structure
design
one hand
can essence
two hands three three hands okay so for
the rest of you let's go briefly over
these models now
try to focus on the different levels of
these models what they're communicating
to us in terms of complexity in terms of
explicitness or implicitness of the
interfaces and overall the amount of
knowledge that is being shared across
the boundaries of the coupled components
so let's start with structure Design
This methodology was introduced
in late 60s early 70s
these books you're probably not going to
find them on Kindle however if you do
manage to find them especially the red
one and you read it without noticing the
publishing date it will sound like the
software engineers in that that time
were struggling with exactly the same
issues as we do today
so it's fascinating
so back then to evaluate coupling they
proposed six levels of
interconnectedness content common
external control stamp and data coupling
this terminology it may sound weird
and we are lucky that it sounds weird
because it is based on languages such as
Kobo and Fortran
so let's see what they mean
the first and the strongest one is
content coupling the idea here is simple
a module uses private interfaces or in
other words implementation details to
communicate with another module
back in those days a typical example of
content coupling would be go to state
statement go to line something so
whoever writes that they know exactly
what happens on that specific line and
if something changes for example another
line is added the integration is going
to break
now nowadays luckily we are not doing
such death defined stunts anymore but we
do have our ways for example reflection
we can use reflection to read the value
of a private field or call a private
method that's content coupling we are
referencing the contents of the module
instead of its public interface
modules are common coupled when they
communicate through a globally
accessible memory space
this shared memory space is unstructured
global binary both modules have to
duplicate the knowledge of how that data
in that memory space is structured now
it is not really documented it naturally
enforced by that memory space
so if one of the modules decides to
change the structure well they better
communicate communicate the change to
all other modules that are sharing that
knowledge and if they are going to
forget a module well the integration is
going to break and
the system won't work anymore
slightly lighter is the external
coupling here instead of unstructured
memory space the modules are using a
global variable
this variable can be a primitive or
array of Primitives it's still shared
memory but at least this time the
interface is somewhat better documented
and it's somehow enforced by that shared
memory space
now to draw examples from our time let's
say that
for common coupling it would be two
modules to communicate by reading and
writing to the same file in S3
well that's just binaries binary data
there and they both have to hold that
knowledge how to format that data
external coupling would be let's say two
modules have to work with the same
database
yeah it's not really a variable or an
array of variables but the idea is the
same we have a shared memory and
the database enforce the format it makes
it easier to see if you're going to
break the integration or not
unlike the previous case
control coupling happens when one module
dictates to another one how to do its
job
now when this terminology was introduced
the example that was you used pretty
much everywhere is a module that passes
some flags that control the execution
flow of another module
and in my opinion a more clear way of
explaining this level is your business
logic is simply not encapsulated in one
module instead it's been split across
multiple modules there is a functional
dependency between the two modules if
the functionality of
the Upstream module will change it will
necessarily affect the downstream module
as well
stamped coupled modules are
communicating by exchanging data records
these data records are data structures
that contain way more information than
is actually needed for integration
say for example I'm communicating with a
CRM module and I'm asking for an email
address of a certain customer instead
I'm getting a whole data structure
containing like tens of hundreds of
other fields well I will find the email
that field that I actually need there
however sharing that extraneous
information makes the consumers more
sensitive to the changes in those data
structures of the Upstream module and
overall it doesn't really reflect what
data is actually needed for integration
the public interface of the Upstream is
wider than it really should be
and finally data coupling this is the
lowest and most desirable level in
structure design here the modules are
communicating by passing arguments with
integration related data only only the
smallest possible subset of data that is
needed for the integration to work in
other words this level maximizes
encapsulation of the knowledge by the
Upstream module
so overall these these levels reflect
how much implementation details are
shared across boundaries starting from
content coupling where almost all
implementation details are being shared
all the way down to data coupling where
the integration interface is both
minimized and it is as explicit as
possible
now these levels of coupling were
defined in late 60s early 70s
and in 90s Miller pay Jones proposed a
different model of measuring coupling
this one is more adapted to the
object-oriented programming Paradigm and
he called it conesance
this word again comes from leading and
it means having been born together
according to Miller components are
defined as born together if a change in
one component requires a change in
another component or if you can
postulate a reasonable change that would
require both components to change now
reasonable is key word here if you have
a module that implements a CRM system
and you're thinking about well what if
tomorrow is going to implement an SMTP
server that's not a reasonable change it
should be more connected to the real
business domain
now compared to structure Design This
model is more detailed here we have a
overall nine levels of
interconnectedness and there they're
divided into two types static in essence
and dynamic Nations
the aesthetic levels they can be
analyzed just by reading the code they
are simply reflecting some compile time
dependencies between the components of a
system let's start with static in
essence and the lowest level here is
kinescence of name which means two
variables need to have the same name in
order to reference the same thing for
example person named arguments or simply
reading a value from some other variable
if you need to know its name you have
connections of name
a very related type of connections is
can essence of type usually they come
together this one means that in order to
reference
something you need to know its type
so it doesn't really make a lot of sense
today to try to
um treat treat them as separate levels
usually they come together they both are
pretty low on knessing scale they're the
lower spots so here we need to know the
type for example whether it's a string
or an integer
can essence of meaning happens when
conventions are used to assign meanings
to values an a trivial example here is
the one on your right status equals
seven that magic value seven what does
it mean well that knowledge has to be
duplicated by whoever is going to use it
the upstream and the downstream modules
they have to agree on the meaning of
seven they have to duplicate that
knowledge
and that makes them can accent by
meaning
next one is kinescence of algorithms and
this one happens when two modules have
to agree on a use of a specific
algorithm in order to understand each
other
typical example here let's say you have
two modules that are communicating by
exchanging encrypted data well they
better use the same algorithm to encrypt
and decrypt the data because if they
don't
the integration is not going to work so
they have that knowledge of how the data
is encrypted decrypted the use of the
algorithm they they need to agree on the
use of a specific algorithm makes them
kinescent by algorithm now
I want to stop here because this name in
essence of algorithm makes it sound as
if
these two modules implement the same
algorithm
and if they were to implement the same
business logic in two places
I would put that level of
interconnectedness way way above four
out of nine I would put it like 9 or 10
or 11 but that's not the case they only
have to agree on the use of a specific
algorithm to understand each other
and then finally we have the knessence
of position
and this one means that instead of
passing values by names they are
communicated as an array whereas the
meaning of each value is defined by its
position in that array now this one
again it's we're lucky that it's not
really common nowadays
but the closest example I can think of
is let's say we have a send email method
and it receives four strings two from
subject and body all fields of the same
type string and it makes it really easy
to make a mistake
for example to start with from and then
put the two address
and it will cause the system to behave
in unintended way so that's an example
of kinescence of position
so these are the levels of static in
essence five five compile time
dependencies that reflect how explicit
or implicit and integration interface is
again in essence of name and type that's
the most explicit
and conditions of position it makes it
really easy to make a mistake in the way
you're communicating with the Upstream
module
second type of connections is kinescence
is the dynamic in essence and this one
these levels can be identified by
examining the runtime behavior of a
system in other words
these levels reflect runtime
dependencies between different
components of a system
the first level here is
kneescence of execution
and
here what we have a number of operations
that have to be executed in a specific
order let's say you're working with a
database so first we have to open a
connection then begin a transaction then
execute a query then we're going to
commit or roll back the transaction and
finally close that transaction these
five methods have to be executed in this
order and that makes them listened by
execution if we start by closing the
connection and then opening it well
maybe something will happen but not
necessarily something that was intended
closely related level is conditions of
timing and here we have two operations
that should be executed in a set period
of time after
if the first of the the first is being
executed
going back to the example of a database
let's say we have open connection and
then if nothing happens for 30 seconds
we have to time it out and that makes
open connection and timeout connection
can Essen by timing we have that set
period of time that connects them
almost the strongest level is the in
essence of value and here we have values
that have to change together
meaning that there's business invariant
or a constraint or business rule that
dictates that these values they have to
change atomically as one big Atomic
transaction or otherwise the system is
going to be an incorrect State and a
typical example here is
let's say we have this data structure
that represents three edges of a
triangle if we change one of the values
in order for that triangle to be
mathematically correct we have to change
the other two values as well
and that makes this data structure
Connection by value
the its data these three Fields they're
recognition by value
and finally the highest level is the
connections of identity
and here we have two objects that must
reference the same instance of another
object in order to function properly a
trivial example here would be two
modules managing the same set of data in
shared database
If instead of sharing the database each
module is going to have its own instance
of the data and the data is not going to
be synchronized between them again the
system will end up in an incorrect state
so they absolutely must reference the
same set of data in order to function
properly and that makes them can accent
by identity
so these are the levels of dynamic in
essence the lowest is execution where we
have to execute different methods in a
specific order and the highest one is
identity where a third object is
introduced and it's used as a shared
memory or shared memory space
and and it has been used by the two
connected modules
now in a sense
it sounds like we can combine the draw
some parallels between these two models
because there are some
um
some common aspects of the design that
are reflected by the two modules however
they're quite different for example
there are things that are reflected in
structure design but are not reflected
in connections and vice versa in both
models they have some blind spots for
example let's say I'm using reflection
to read the value of a private field
where does it put me on the
structure design scale
what do you think
come on quiz time
up up yep content coupling because we
are accessing something that wasn't
intended for integration
the worst level
to use reflection to read the value of a
private field what do I need to know
where does it put me on the connection
scale
down yep lowest level I need to know its
name and type
so one model says your code sucks
the second says your code is awesome go
figure
also using the terminology from
structure design can be somewhat
challenging today if you want to sound
smart you can use that terminology you
can say well that microservice
introduces control coupling
you will sound super smart nobody is
going to understand what you want but
if that's what you need it will work
anyway uh
so these two models one was introduced
in the late 60s another one in the late
a or early 90s
and this Cadence of 30 years between
them makes now a perfect time to start
thinking about another way of evaluating
strength between a coupled components
now I want to show you a model that I
call integration strength it's something
that I've been using for quite some time
now and I find it way more practical and
simply more useful more approachable
easy to use Easy to implement and I want
to show it to you basically what it does
it simply combines the previous two
models in another
with another terminology that is more a
easy to understand
so here we have only four levels
first one is intrusive then functional
model and contract coupling
as the name suggests intrusive coupling
is the highest level and it's synonymous
to structure designs content coupling
there is something intrusive that that
is happening something that was not
supposed to happen
so modules are integrated through
private interfaces they are using
something that wasn't intended for
integration just as in content coupling
in structured design again needless to
say that such integration method is
fragile and implicit
whoever is in charge of that Upstream
module they have
they have no idea that integration is
even taking place so any change they're
going to make to their implementation
details it it has the potential to break
the integration so here we are assuming
as if all knowledge is being shared
across the boundary of the Upstream
module whether it was it was intentional
or unintentional the end result is the
same
next functional coupling
this one happens when
connected modules are implemented
implementing closely related business
functionality
its practical implication is that the
same business requirements are going to
trigger simultaneous changes in both
components in a sense the levels of
dynamic in essence
they all reflect this kind of
relationship
functional coupling also in addition to
the the levels of dynamic in essence an
extreme example here would be two
modules duplicating the same business
logic
if that duplicated business logic has to
change simultaneously by the two modules
that's the extreme case of functional
coupling and to make it even more
implicit they don't have to be connected
this can be totally decoupled components
of a system that are not working
together in any way they just have to
change together and whoever is going to
implement the change they have to keep
that in mind that we have to change that
logic in multiple places
a lower level of integration strength is
model coupling
this one means that the components are
based on the same model of the business
domain this level is somewhat similar to
structure design stamp coupling where
the Upstream modules module shares way
more information about its internal
structure than is actually needed for
integration
having to change that model in multiple
places as in the previous case it makes
it more difficult to improve that model
to evolve it and to change it over time
again we are sharing way more knowledge
than is needed for integration and it
makes the system more prone to cascading
changes
now in a sense we can say that the
levels of static in essence in essence
of name type all the way to position
they reflect this kind of relationship
and finally the lowest level of
integration strength is contract
coupling here the components are
integrated through an explicit
integration specific model that is
decoupled as much as possible from their
implementation model
meaning that the implementation can
evolve independently of that integration
contract if you are familiar with domain
driven design then openhost service
publish language and the corruption
layer all these patterns reflect this
kind of relationship relationship that
encapsulates as much knowledge as
possible about the upstream and exposes
another model which is more oriented
towards integration
that model is intended to contain all
changes to the implementation model and
avoid cascading changes as much as
possible
so these are the four levels of
integration strength they reflect the
amount of knowledge that is shared
across components boundaries and how
implicit or explicit the integration
interfaces are
intrusive coupling shares the most
knowledge about how that Upstream module
is implemented functional coupling
reduces the knowledge from how to what
what has been implemented
and
model coupling reduces it further it
reduces the knowledge to the knowledge
of the business domain that is being
used by the Upstream module and finally
Contra coupling minimizes the shared
knowledge to the knowledge of
integration interfaces the bare minimum
that is needed for integration to work
now let's say that we have two
components integrated through intrusive
coupling
does it mean that this design is
necessarily good or bad what do you
think
quiz time
sorry
bad okay other opinions
oh
hello fellow Consultants
yeah it depends so let's continue
the next Dimension is the dimension of
space or a distance and turns out the
physical location of components it also
affects their level of coupling and the
thing is the connections between a
systems components they can span
different distances these distances can
are they're closely related to what we
usually call levels of abstraction we
can have coupling between individual
statements between methods classes
namespaces components microservices or
whole systems
now the question is what do we have on
that vertical axis what do you think
sorry
time
yes
Yes actually yeah
that's the first time getting the answer
right away
so
first of all it represents the
coordination effort that is required to
implement a change or in other words how
long will it take to implement the
change the time or the effort that is
required the longer the distance between
the elements that have to be changed
together the more coordination effort is
required to actually make the change in
other words the cost of change is
proportional to the distance between the
affected components the further they are
apart the harder it's going to be to
coordinate the change let's say you have
to change two lines in the same method
that's going to be orders of magnitude
easier than to change two microservices
simultaneously which by definition
shouldn't be changed simultaneously
but that's not the only effect of
distance
it also affects the component's life
cycle coupling in other words how in
related are their life cycles as the
components are located closer to each
other the higher the chances that
changing one of them will inadvertently
inadvertently affect other components as
well for example if you are changing a
method of a class chances are that you
will also have to change other methods
in the same class
and the closer these elements are to
each other the harder probability for
such cascading changes
and what's interesting is that
the distance between components
it defined not only by their physical uh
physical location in the code base but
also by the organizational structure
let's say that we have that extreme
example on the right here of two
microservices
now we can talk about two cases the
first one is two microservices that have
to change together and they're
implemented by the same team versus two
microservices implemented by different
teams in the latter case we need more
integration am
more communication and more coordination
effort to make that change happen
despite the fact that in terms of levels
of abstraction we're on the same level
but still in that case of multiple teams
we have higher distance
now let's say that we have some
high level of integration strength
functional
between two systems which means that the
distance between them is almost
extremely high the integration strength
is high as well but
I want to ask you the same question is
this design necessarily bad
or what
yeah it depends
and sorry
could it be better yeah let's see huh
so to answer this question we can also
ask another question if a tree falls in
a forest and nobody is around to hear it
fall does it make a sound
so if strongly connected components over
a large distance never change
how the coupling is going to affect us
so let's talk about the Third Dimension
the dimension of time or volatility
and the main question that we have to
ask here is how often do we expect that
Upstream component to change
now it's difficult to make predictions
especially about the future as they say
however we can use some tools from
existing methodologies to evaluate
a where should we expect the high stress
rate of changes in a system and as a
domain driven design Fanboy guess what
methodology I'm going to use the
management design
and the part of domain driven design
that can help us here is subdomains
so according to domain driven design
your business domain is composed of
individual business building blocks
subdomains
a subdomain
it defines a fine grade functionality
that required for a business to succeed
in a more technical language it's a set
of cohere in strongly interrelated use
cases use cases that work on the same
set of data for example or simply use
cases that are going to be affected by
the same changes in the business
requirements
what's interesting for us is not all
subdomains are the same we have three
types core supporting and generic
core is all about the company's
competitive Advantage these are
inventions optimizations intellectual
properties everything that
differentiates the company from its
competitors eventually this is how the
company plans to make profits
generic subdomains are the opposite
these are the solved problems these are
the problems that already have accepted
Solutions in form of of the Shelf
products or open source projects that
you can buy or adopt and
and use that and forget about that
problem overall
for example
um
identity in Access
it may be interesting to implement
identity and access solution but if you
have limited budget then probably you
shouldn't do it also encryption
algorithm very interesting problem to
solve but only if that's your core
business
otherwise it's going to be an expensive
problem to solve so that's a generic
subdomain
and finally we have supporting
subdomains which are somewhere in the
middle
no ready-made solution exists as in the
case of core sub domains however they
are not really providing any competitive
Advantage for the company
the company has to implement them but if
there would be an existing solution they
would jump on it they would use it
because that would allow them to save
some time and work on something more
important so usually these areas
supporting subdomains they are simple
there is no complexity here usually
these are crowd data entry interfaces
ETL jobs stuff that
you either want to Outsource or you
would be happy to use an existing
solution for
so overall that makes core subdomains
the most volatile business is interested
in changing them as frequently as they
can because they wanted to optimize them
they wanted to increase the competitive
advantage that they can gain by
implementing a core subdomain in a
unique and in a competitive way
so when evaluating coupling between
components
we can ask that question what sub domain
of the option component are we looking
at is it a core or supporting or generic
if it's core then we should expect very
high volatility there
so these are the three dimensions of
coupling that describe the nature of the
relationship between two connected
components now let's see what insights
can we get by combining them so first
strength and volatility the higher the
strength the higher the probability of
cascading changes they are the
volatility the more often we will have
to take care of those cascading changes
so when both are high we get high
maintenance effort
strength and distance
in the components physically increases
the coordination effort that is needed
to implement a change that affects
multiple components
High integration strength makes those
cascading changes frequent
so overall High distance over High a
high strength over High distance is
going to be
a challenging challenging to maintain
and finally distance and volatility
these two reflect the coordination
effort that is needed to evolve that
system if both are high expect
communication overload
frequent communication between different
teams or different organization units
that Implement those two modules
now that's not the whole picture
to get the whole picture we need to
combine the three dimensions together
and combining them together allows us to
estimate the pain we are going to endure
by maintaining that relationship over
time
now we can evaluate that Pain by simply
multiplying the values of the three
dimensions
pain maintenance pain is the strength of
the relationship times the volatility of
the relationship times the distance
between the components
meaning that if all three are high the
pain you are going to suffer is going to
be high as well
now following this mathematical
reasoning let's say that
we're dealing with a simple scale here
low or high so low will be zero how is
going to be one if we wanna to ensure
that the pain is minimal it's zero what
should we do
yes multiply by zero all we need is to
make one of them zero and overall the
pain is going to be zero as well if we
can reduce the integration strength to
the minimum
or contract coupling it's okay to have
high volatility over High distance
cascading changes will require lots of
collaboration efforts but that minimal
strength it also minimizes the number of
such cascading changes that are going to
happen
if both integration strengths and
volatility are high
and there is nothing you can do about it
for example you have two modules that
implement the same functionality
they're going to be affected by the same
changes in the business requirements no
matter what you do
you will be stuck with that functional
dependency so that's going to be a
functional coupling
so
to balance this relationship what we can
do is to minimize the distance so that
those cascading changes when they are
going to happen they won't require High
coordination efforts so it's going to be
simpler in other words this relationship
represents what we usually call High
cohesion we are putting in related
things close to each other
and finally if the volatility is zero
sometimes high strength over High
distance is acceptable let's say you are
integrating with a legacy system
by definition you know that it's a
legacy system it's not going to change
they're not going to be new
functionalities added to it it's not
going to be refactored so it's okay for
example to fetch its database directly
from its its data directly from its
database
so in a sense you introduce an intrusive
coupling here but it's balanced by
minimal volatility
so to sum it up the algorithm to
minimize the pain is to estimate or is
to eliminate all accidental coupling
meaning that if you have high strength
see if you can lower it
or reduce it not always you can do it
sometimes that
um integration strength is essential
sometimes you need High functional
dependency between the connected
components or you simply need that
model to be shared between the two
components for example again I'm wearing
my DDD hat bounded context reduces the
distance because they have to work with
the same model that's the definition of
a bounded context a boundary of a model
so in a sense it reduces The Distance by
separating the usage of that model from
other bounded contexts
so reduce that integration strength as
much as possible and if all fails if you
are stuck with high volatility
and high strength you can balance it by
reducing the distance
by
by putting those in related components
closer to each other
we have time for a few examples
so let's see
we know that referencing let's say we're
building a microservices based system
and we know that using another
microservices database directly is a big
No-No we should not do it so let's
analyze this scenario of using another
Services a database directly and where
it puts us on this scale of integration
strength integration strength
so the first case is let's say that the
database was never intended to be shared
meaning that the Upstream module doesn't
even know that somebody reads that data
that makes this relationship intrusive
the highest level of integration
strength
however the authors of the two modules
or two components
they might have agreed to use that data
for some reason whether good or bad but
they're aware of it it's not
the sum module doing it without the
Upstream even know knowing about it or
without exiting its private interfaces
it was agreed that that database is
going to be used by the two modules or
the two com should kind of
so that's puts us on the functional
coupling level
another example let's say we have bi
department and what do they love to do
they love to take our data from
operational systems just copy it
and then analyze it and then if there is
a change in the operational system
schema that produces some noise that
comes from the bi side
thus by doing that they introduced model
coupling
and finally that database might be there
because it contains data that is
intended for integration
it is meant to be shared for example
data mesh
sorry
the data mesh approach it assumes that
you are going to share integration
specific data by sharing a database so
in that case it's going to be contract
coupling
next example microservices
now don't know about you but and I
encountered many situations in which
companies looked at their monolith and
decided that it's not fashionable
anymore they need microservices
what should what should we do first
let's do a POC let's extract some
functionality
and let's use some interesting strategy
for decomposing that monolith into
microservices like saying that a
microservice should be no longer than
20 lines of code
and they're doing it
and it works
and they're happy about it and they say
okay this microservices approach it's
awesome so next what we are going to do
is to decompose all of our business
logic following with the same reasoning
and then they end up with a distributed
monolith
what usually happens is when they're
doing a POC they're not going to do it
with business critical functionality
right they're going to start with
supporting or generic subdomains
so they have high strength over a high
distance that is balanced by low
volatility but they continue with the
same approach and decompose their core
sub domains then they have the three of
them high high strength High distance
High volatility High pain and then they
block that microservices are evil
um
or serverless functions
okay we have
more time so
I will quickly go over the my German
design because you know
I am a deadly guy
so aggregates
the strength is high by definition if
you have an aggregate the strength this
High volatility is high as well because
usually these are core subdomains so
what we are doing DDD says bring them
close to each other put them in the same
boundary reduce the distance
supporting subdomains according to DDD
this is where you can run some Corners
this is where you can use some rapid
application development framework and
not get crazy with Event Source and
Aggregates all that stuff this is where
you can do the simplest thing that is
going to work why because the volatility
is low so it balances the high strength
that you may introduce by using those
simpler implementation techniques
finally as I mentioned before
anti-corruption layer open hot service
published language these patterns for
defining the integration between bounded
contexts
their goal is to minimize the strength
to encapsulate as much knowledge as
possible about the implementation
details of each bounded context and
share an integration specific model
and with that we can wrap this whole
thing up
so again coupling it's
an inherent part of system design
we cannot avoid it it's always going to
be there and it happens in three
dimensions we can use different models
for evaluating the strength of the
relationship this is the one I love
because
it combines two models connections and
structured design
it reflects how much knowledge is shared
across components boundaries
then we have the distance the
relationship across physical distances
between the connected components the
closer there are to each other the
higher the life cycle coupling they have
to be tested deployed together
and the further they are apart the
harder it's going to be to change them
simultaneously if you have to it will
require a higher coordination effort
and we have volatility
and the question we're asking here the
option module that shares that knowledge
across its boundary
how often it is going to change and we
can use the management designs
subdomains to evaluate that rate of
change we can also use Conway's map to
evaluate that and I'm sure there are
other techniques
overall if we combine the three
dimensions together we can get
maintenance pain
if the three values are high
your life is not going to be pretty in
the future
when you will have to implement
Cascadian changes
now I said in the beginning that
it's not going to be a sales pitch it's
not you can use that model however if
one day this book will be published you
will find a more elaborate a formula
there that takes into account
some other Concepts like complexity to
introduce them here I would need another
two hours so yeah
what we have here is maintenance pain
right now
so again I hope that I will finish this
book before it finishes me hopefully
it's going to happen this year cannot
promise anything at this point of time
but
thank you do we have any questions
we still have
four and a half minutes
yeah any questions one any questions two
three four five no questions that means
we still have a few more minutes so I'm
not going to waste it sorry
we are going to take a selfie here
say hi
thank you